that way ticket is fun now where are so
full podcast welcome to the Warsaw food
podcast it is a hundred agrees outside
we got Rodrigo here that's what I'm
talking about is fire season yeah man
robberies at Orson house what a Philippe
talk to us the fire season man that
means fire ants for saw black ants yeah
though sting you dog stay away stay away
from Pam so red as I see them for real
those carriers and other blackboard
because cuz I never see them but when I
see under huge that pecan all fool what
welcome to the hilarious talk to me
though I don't want to brag you mad but
I said to a bomb yet today I tell jump
in my pool got stung by be dog at the
same time these stingrays gotta stay out
of the water bro don't worry for me
about Aquaman awkwardness it was it a
beer or what I don't know man but when I
got to the other side of the water of
the ocean is like yeah this guy has a
pocket huge pool now when I got to the
other side I just ducked to something
lower throws a branch but like a bee
uh-huh and man it's dog dogs at first I
was a batty flop bird a belly flop burns
it was burning the side of me but
there's a southern fool ah
I got hot that's true to a baby please
had to jump out of the water I look for
medication eat the rattlesnake man get
anything cut this blood out of here so
man that hurt war so fool I meant I
meant our miracle eita in the house
hahaha machine you forever my LOV mo
there happen if he does you know like
what who I met I met one of the comedian
that I know he was there where I was at
picture was there oh hell yeah
he goes there to him and um Rivera are a
week or a month before I get there
Dominique I ran I loved our era was so
full with no further ado we have a meta
made a comedian but I met years ago
bailed if we had a roommate
Whittier bro all right wait here it was
called hold on a second
it was it was a stick now it was called
everybody's to do now know if it's
Pasadena you had it way before I was are
you talking about the Montebello though
you had a relay there you had a room and
also in my dad he's a Whittier accused
that's right kids on and Pasadena that's
right everybody to clothe about Willie
Jeff
Freeza Freeza love was that before or
even Eddie Griffin 1994 yeah because I
was working at a restaurant in Pasadena
I was working at Kevin Costner's
restaurant and we used to do a comedy
night there I meant and then they then
they cancelled it and I was like well I
want to go find another room and we
would just walked into cues one night
they had that side room remember
yeah it was like a billiard hall and
then there was like the side room with
the stage was perfect for comedy
and look the thigh stage was a light on
and not all the lights uh-huh for the
lights with a regular light or not the
DJ lights on and a club like a like a
[ __ ] school auditorium well I was
like it was a deep room remember guys
keep an auditorium with no cheat no
sleep we had to put chairs in there and
every night man rain and freeze love
would close it out every night remember
that Eddie Griffin would come in there
do our fool damned is that blue child
days whoo-chow
was that after uh gosh uh no that's old
ninety before year 95 well that was a
really Montebello wild coyotes tortillas
tortilla or that Gotham's was a call
Gotham Joker first got those when you
went there so healing will their adopted
anyone's called Gotham whoa no when I
first started doing comedy
somebody said hey man you got to go
check out this room it's in Montebello
you know it's like back then it was you
it was all really Willie Barcena and
Jeff Jeff Garcia and lovely and fluffy
yeah
you guys are like that five like name
another vacation I remember a black
person really only woody could walk in
their bed and both of buddy but the
crowds were always great oh yeah they're
awesome crowd because they pay to get in
Oh preciate it was charge of $2 and $3
they always charge them yeah
so they started charging them because
they were dazed to have a really really
hot karaoke night on Friday I mean I'm
in the manga will show up bro and seeing
um I think God bless america
Rolling Stones Throw it was a good rule
to UM to trial stuff but I'm Nam it was
rowdy to those rowdy yet without it
East LA basically just people just shout
and [ __ ] out for no reason they didn't
know man they were open mic into the
audience okay i sooo much mercy i could
tell the audience sometimes you know man
it's not my fault that were horrible
tonight you guys failed as an audience
you guys [ __ ] are horrible you're the
worst audience ever yours are not ready
to go to a Laugh Factory
yes I'm not ready for somebody welcome
to and tell you sir it's a two-drink
minimum
you're not ready for sitcoms nobody's
not ready for us for anything ah damn it
just wanna yeah sorry done I remember
this chola i just a chola because she is
a chola and they had just finished the
rate the the Lakers were playing and the
playoffs and has to stop the game to do
comedy comedy night so the game was
already over and then I brought up
there's a print will acquit rom Holmwood
from the hood would from the hood would
enough wood for the hell oh no the
original Willie and Lester they're all
matter how the big gums big teeth the
one that was called woody then because I
do for mobile is that other guy says
woody work for the hood yeah does it
worry i woody okay and then there's that
other guy did with Roscoe and that
roster the gotta go to bed and beat that
you grew up with yeah that because
William Tyler that with all times after
I was becoming there's an older guy it
has woody yeah that's a fool yeah that
was his dogs just like like a hood dude
I don't talk you know tom is USO tours I
go man that guy we were doing a short
see son and he was trying to be you know
that comedian joke around you know like
I mean I made my do a joke you know
whatever the situation is you know could
we like busted out jokes but never hung
out
at will a good guy book we [ __ ] saw
his dog but there Joker ha ha ha his dog
tacos are but to the joint Babel fool he
looked at me don't let it like Africa
dull hey guys uh you know I'm Mexican
dog hey hanging you know those [ __ ]
out the skulls Presidente like there's
everywhere Bulldogs and then he look to
a reason yeah man what do you kind of
scared right now
little took the wood the dog the [ __ ]
would put it yeah keep me out digging so
that's a different relic with that
putter [ __ ] the bully for the act
because you bust it out like we're
talking politician a boob man
Wow little opinion well they had one of
those who have one of those Conan was it
didn't Conan O'Brien do that on the show
for a while
got some hood dog that puppet oh yeah
the one was over 12 it's still dog yeah
that's right insult dog for me to poop
on beagle and then another time of the
best ever in Twitter quiz with humoral
how do you know all 9 Tony
I don't know knowing I watched bad
comedy Willi and Tyler is nothing like
guys I know from the comedy so you know
he was who more is right writer you more
he was on that on Sinbad show and he
came out there he was shy Tony and he
but a little puppet right but the puppet
didn't say [ __ ] he just whispered him in
a vehicle just yeah shite honest a he's
happy to be remember Twitter cause it
was just a sketch yeah that's funny
that's hilarious though it was funny
then he did that little Frankenstein's
creature back comedy what happened I was
doing a show in Arizona with myself you
know and Paul Rodriguez party we went
out first
dude it was a hundred six degrees
outside and you know they wanted to come
here to perform first outside and do 20
minutes you chose an outside gigs wanna
go to God can't do comedy and and he
looking really like this hey guys
there's a visor bro we did it me
umbrella horuseus I knew what I don't
know what poetry is bringing a bag oh I
think he got to the rule like a
professional
he has show clothes and come outside
close so he put in so close he would you
know like sometimes you know it's 25
minutes polishing is there fuckin'-a she
started walking into the audience and
started making fun of fools like he was
doing that show in San Quentin he was
just making fun of everybody in the
audience took photos he did a meaning
greed for like 50 minutes in this yeah I
did another 20 so he did like 30 then I
went up there so when I tell more people
were sitting down grew and I got laughs
for 26 29 minutes got off and then the
ban tears I want me to bring a mob room
they were [ __ ] up hi
well we're updated to do so but a buster
cowbell hug you [ __ ] who didn't
know who the [ __ ] I was I was crazy dog
now can I start like better Jake ha ha
ha ha ha ha - you were gonna kill them
but after somebody said would you plug
in a Taco Bell from the - yeah - put
that [ __ ] up on a drum still oh it's
gonna be - Oh bro dog [ __ ] idiot dog
ain't you gonna do you get a black kid
it man
Grammy winner again I took a bus or a
joke because okay man the other I did
the best of the era they did it they
need it the better the mix Tierra then
the best of the best of the era -
because war was late are you serious
yeah war was scheduled I never see I've
seen comedians to go over and do more
time well the headliners late right my
narrow stretch and they were thinking
they were looking for a band member from
the other best to bring you up a taste a
little encore pad we have Malo mr.
singer of Malo compatible shows up at
our sing it I should've been like we got
Paul Rodriguez and Felipe Esparza know
what I could do another set apologies
they go back up it a rebel because not
knock who's there war wars gonna be late
haha that's a legend we were leaving
there was people like cuz I wouldn't go
to my room you know smoke a little Joe
come back to your ward shows up so we're
back to earlier to my room that lady
stopped me you know cause she's excuse
me I met you backstage with Paul mama
wants to know if war is gonna go on soon
because we have to go pick up our family
right now
they're over there like you're picking
up their family like Motorola's just I
know she's not checkin up on a stage
room like study a personal problem bro
like she lost her mom had to go pick up
somebody up do you feel that like people
who love comedy now these fuller they
have a right to ask you content the
questions don't even matter
gotta do it [ __ ] comedy all the time
when you get I'm gonna mount it yeah I I
get like a lot of political [ __ ] all
right
yeah like so you're at home playing huh
well what do you thinks you know what
can happen with the world I'm like I
don't even know you know we got a new
[ __ ] tribe president I get a lot of
missed cultural misunderstanding too
you know people are like oh that's tight
IT guy Jeff I know you're for the rack
that's not from Egypt okay okay Egyptian
deigning but people always tell you the
problems people always want to come up
to you and say oh and here's the thing I
hate the most
man I got a funny joke for you you
should use this onstage at that time I
hate that I would say no you don't and
save your breath you thought of that I
say that sometimes sometimes I'll get a
little funny one what I'm like that's a
hack I heard that before you you got
that out of a book right but sometimes
people think they're jokes are so funny
I'm just I'm just like man now as I keep
doing P state be an accountant your
lucky bra got people coming at me in
Spanish with jokes I got how waiters
cook with cookie stats cuz I passed by
when you at the improv is that I passed
the cookie staff to get into the kitchen
something might still want grease they
know you get up ready to go up on stage
walk up walk on stage smile and fries
bro [ __ ] Python you stay closer to me
later on it you tomato cheese toss away
it was basically a party to way yeah bro
you're you cook your prize she was four
years kinda line
you know even a sous-chef yesterday the
table shows our Spanish are funny but
they're not jokes that I would say on
stage because they don't translate it'll
translate matter now finally it's the
same thing in the Arab culture Arabs
will tell you a joke in Arabic and there
is gold
it sounds what's poker is not a book
yeah don't say anything which is total
written Arabic and then they try to say
in English that never works in Arabic it
never works but um they always have like
Arabs have a really dry sense of humor
like you know you you don't be like
that's that's what was funny you know
it's like are you gonna kill me and you
know you never know if they're actually
being honest or whatever if see it seems
like it's opened up a little bit more
with the Arab culture but I think the
Latin culture is really the most
flavorful the culture when it comes to
to humor even like more than black
people like that oh yeah because black
people love stand-up comedy but like
that Latinos you guys love love love to
laugh and and and you guys show up on
time too so you know that's that's what
counts but you don't look to laugh but
didn't but they'll give everybody the
benefit of doubt not a black people like
some audiences like the they were awake
a sense fear angle like Walker Yogi's
but those there's fears
oh you'll sit on you know simple once
they start sensing premise oh here we go
so I was at The Improv one night
showcasing for The Tonight Show and I
don't know why they chose mo better
Mondays but they were like yeah yeah Bob
Reed back at the time was booked he's
like okay calm down about the improv
woman I hadn't been in LA in a while so
I didn't realize it was a black room
Aguirre was running it you he hosted do
you raise my friend so he does some time
and he brings me up and they said do
four minutes don't touch the mic stand
just talk as if you're going to do it
tonight cent show you know slammer and I
was like I I went into my first joke
nothing second joke crickets third joke
some black woman from the back of rooms
yelled out say something funny
[ __ ] and then everybody just
chimed in like a pack of word and they
booed me off stage and I said all right
a like a substitute teacher thank you
very much and walked off stage and da
went up and like reamed um you stupid
[ __ ] that's
he was showcasing for The Tonight Show
you guys gotta have more respect you
guys were booed Katt Williams and he
just like ripped into the audience and
like you know like schooled them I'm on
a half
it was weird like I never had a comic
don't tell her audience you know hey you
can't act like that he's you know he was
trying out something new and then he
came up to me afterward but it was a
weird experience because they don't have
they smell fear they only have a little
bit of patience and then if they don't
like this boom you're out it's like you
don't catch that wave man you know cast
away but you can't avoid with the
long-ass stories they don't know us
yeah yeah they don't know you just get
to the first funny joke you have the
second one a third and then do your long
story right to become accustomed you
gotta be cameo tonight man just imitate
about sedation eggs
ya know how to be a bond pounding what's
up fool memorable way to run into I met
a man at the bowling alley
yeah dude Hollywood lay right there or
down in like tourist school or so
there's no people how it was that the
spot well that day back in the day
Hollywood lanes was 24 hours a day what
was on Santa Monica Boulevard yeah
barely it had a bar it was all you
always see like celebrities in there
like ran like Keanu rockstars are
celebrities and no one would ever bother
that all but I go in there I used to go
in there with what some actor friends of
mine and we used to only see like their
God Vince was a was ISA was a used to go
in there together and Peter Billingsley
cole hauser some of these like young
Hollywood actors I used to hang out with
back in the day but you'd always see
these really like uber like this wasn't
that famous back then but he was looking
this was after swing errors in like he
hadn't done like his big movies yet so
it wasn't really on the radar but then
you'd see like big a-list movie stars
hanging out in there and just drinking
like cold beers and bowling and then
he'd see like always like you know
Mexican families hanging out you know
yeah how do I there that's why I was so
cool because you know the family is
oftentimes the families wouldn't even
know
Keanu Reeves was bowling next to them
right if he just didn't look you know
you just would never expect you know a
guy like that there whatever but that
was a cool place man Hollywood billiards
over that place they took all that stuff
down back in the con
late 90s Hollywood laze bro those balls
were chipped haha everything up in there
that will you know take you an hour to
find a good bowling ball yeah that's
true
Hey look at you pucks there's good fight
at a bar yeah yeah and they're like they
have them they have like this short they
fought but big the basket it might run
cleaner before Billabong right mm-hm
laughter IDs do you were anywhere near a
couple times when I saw you in swingers
I was like oh look I'm in I'm in real
quick you know that guy ha ha ha ha ha
tie mystery I had two lines I I'm the
actor who always has to explain the part
he's in like if somebody says hey you
seen that this movie and they go yeah he
was Mike in telling you know that movie
he did they go I go no I'm like you've
never seen in a movie when the house is
on fire and everybody's running out and
the last guy that ran out
that wasn't me there was one more guy
after him that was me you know I had a
red shirt on and people are like oh yeah
I always have to explain my role I mean
when I was to bring up Ernie G Bros was
it [ __ ] it I'm Jerry Maguire oh [ __ ]
never seen that [ __ ] man I wanna watch
amateur Maguire wait try closin up DVD
bro cause that [ __ ] you know the bonus
is it was it how do you might know is
back you see is back here with a
hologram to transcode oh my god they
really gonna pause it right over the
hotel you gotta tell them about Jerry
Maguire bro how about you I could get
embarrassed if you were trouble to bring
up their credit cuz in the crowd believe
that I believe - I don't like doing that
I don't hear back in the day used to
always want to be like I you know Thomas
told Matt it's not like there's an agent
in the room in Arizona was gonna butcher
the caster's fool finally I see him
right right oh I said I'm gonna catch
him in Wisconsin you know that's where
he's gonna he's gonna make his big break
that I if you're like even if you're
doing like a showcase I doesn't matter
like okay you were on this you what are
you doing now like what does it mean now
you know I would think it's funny comics
were always do like you know tell him I
just finished my half-hour Showtime
special
doing a guest spot and so-and-so sure
took okay well just just google.you and
we don't again all right hello IMDB you
tell now I'm working on you on my new
HBO special we are going live taping
resume t-shirt ugh god damn all bad but
uh the best one was out with the
comedian who passed away that was the
one who can heat he to have that the
Reuben long [ __ ] like cave us his name
just passed away she look like black oh
video Nam welcome to the Colorado random
[ __ ] drawing a blank here there
Rickey Rickey smiley Rickey smiley now
Ricky hooks Ricky honor talking Ricky is
pretty Harris never hosted a shoulder I
was on and another comedian Black Widow
went up the deal with snowballs snow
cone okö no man I would they call have
snow something's slowly abroad or no he
pulled out the harmonica then yeah no
not that like I hear the black dude
here's what he spoke Regents a
barbershop bro and took round without
pain that fool went up a date promoted
another show was gonna happen in that
spot on Friday
yeah mom earthquake will be there
Cece Peniston he'll be there um Snoop
Dogg said he might be there fool Ricky
Harry went up there what's all that home
and [ __ ] name chop it up here and
then he had to DJ play like a small
little beat you're going it was like it
was like human Australia yeah man even
though her mother [ __ ] be up here just
name-dropping clinic a little bit he was
recording with a beat yeah and also
Snoop Dogg's gonna be Lauren's day he
might show up he's got a plan babysitter
he like a 10-minute bit about shout out
that facility yeah hilarious done he was
snowboarder what's up boo I remember I
saw Vince Vaughn tonight show when
you're promoting that true you are on
wall west tour and he mentioned you yeah
man I was cool you see her like you were
detained and
Perry were pissed off that you were
comedian they uh yeah well you know I
don't know how your parents started out
when you know when you first said you're
going to be in I told my mom and dad I
was going to be I told my dad I'm gonna
move to Hollywood to be an actor in a
comedian and he said what are you a gay
I said hi he said what are you a gay I
said it's not a game it's just a game
but no I'm not I mean it's like you're
gonna join a cult and the Jews what
Hollywood and you're never going to work
and I was like just just slow down
just slow down he was kind of right ha
ha ha ha if I tell you he said are you
gonna be a agent ha ha ha ha they didn't
like it at first and then I got my first
I think it was the first movie I did a
small I played a terrorist and I see
after session was that before that was
after that ok not that was I was an
extra in there that's why I met Vince
Vaughn and Peter they wrote they were
both Peter was a child star he was the
kid from a Christmas story
yeah and then he his career kind of you
know he I had kids it was it was kind of
declining as an actor but then he was
kind of coming up as a producer editor
now he's a big producer director and
stuff now but at the time his career was
kind of dwindling as an actor and Vince
Vaughn was unknown at the time and they
played best friends in this after-school
special and I was an extra on the on the
show and we just all became friends and
then you know they did this tour which
was really cool but what the movie I did
after that was executive decision why
play terrorist number four number four
dog and then funny in the credits it
says the terrorist name on board right
says I met I met there's a fourth of
Emily no Kurt Russell same thing
airplane is terrorist yeah and then my
dad was like oh my god that was my son
was so proud oh he didn't talk to you
for seven years now my dad disowned me
then you know plugs around little bit
well you don't have to try it out before
you disowned you know dudes like right
out of the gate
cuz you know when I first got to
Hollywood I didn't know anybody I was a
waiter I was a personal trainer which
acting classes I was just like ice cold
cold I didn't know anybody because
you're originally from
from Riverside I grew up a Riverside and
I thought for me LA from Riverside was
like a big sparkly place you know in
Hollywood and I was like you know
[ __ ] that I'm gonna go try it you
know learn and see if I can you know
sink my teeth into it and I just kind of
fell in love with it right but yeah it
was a harder than you know so my dad the
whole time the whole journey he was just
like you know might he would you know
because all the other Arab fathers would
have sons and like my son I just got
those messes degree and engineering my
daughter just gotten PhD and medical
what is your son doing he is a gay he
moved to Hollywood he joined the cult
and I know it's like and then so now
it's the you know the warm turn now all
his fans were like your son we're so
proud can he slide this with my daughter
you know it's crazy how like an all
comes around full circle but that was a
man we were in Houston I think the first
time we were in Houston I don't know if
you're with me were driving without with
a cab driver and a cab driver was
talking about how he to own all the
businesses before I remember he's gonna
pitch up he opened another pet shops he
was a business you're the Arab guy he
goes oh man
he was timing everything I had to I had
seven businesses my brother came stole
it you know whatever right but he can't
say how much he loved the axis of evil
oh really I mean we loved her it calm
man I made man he was like he was like
he was like to him and felt like finally
finally you know someone does comedy and
speaks about us here in America on an
app on a map it's like when you over the
first time somebody saw powered vegan
for the first time it was like you know
you guys were like the first men on the
moon to him you know who I paid tribute
for that whole thing is Mitzi shore the
owner of the Comedy Store already I
started it she started a thing called
Arabian Nights oh yeah right Arabian we
switched it with the name to axis of
evil because President Bush coined the
phrase we don't label but Maz Jobrani is
Iranian so we were getting a lot of you
know Iranian saying don't you can't call
it a taking and we're not that of that
person I'm like
I am fired Shannon like that I thought
300 but okay we'll change that so I was
changed and then we got we got you know
we got on Comedy Central we went to the
Middle East and did our art did big
Middle East tour then split up and get
our own she rocks she's supposed to
we're talking about doing a reunion
10-year reunion tour this year in the
Middle East we'll see how that goes but
yeah we that was a tricky thing because
it was like walking on the moon a little
bit it was a little bit like because no
one else was doing go first no one was
doing it you know not really like on the
scale that we were doing it you know
much like you guys you're pioneers in
the sense we're like you really spoke to
the people you know and people wanted to
hear that this - oh we're on that show
catalyst yeah I thought was oh yeah yeah
like we huh no we had which we tapped a
new young audience the judge ever seen
the noob like the perineal George Lopez
was but the kids didn't know George look
right now right now everybody's got a
whole new audience but there were people
were excited man like did all our shows
were badass even before he hosted when
they right when it became gay locals
from that community and Bobby bites and
all that [ __ ] and it started getting
real good and then George Lopez hosted
it was real good
you guys roll they're having like
slamming a set it was just like an only
thing I like [ __ ] ah how you guys felt
in the beginning that would you guys
like nervous or they were they're gonna
work out in the beginning
well Mitzi shore was letting us use the
comedy store to like craft car material
and then it started getting good and
like you know and we were doing all self
deprecation material you know like oh I
can't fly anywhere you know my name is a
nine list you know I got a show up to
the airport a g-strain shipment that was
our the first
jokes back then then I started evolving
into like stories people like I said -
got it - get on your side but in the
beginning and we were testing it out we
knew that we had something good when we
went to Washington DC and sold 2,000
seats at the Warner Theatre and it was
funny because we were trying the improv
was giving us Mondays Tuesdays and
Wednesdays same here and then you're
like I don't know like hey can we get a
weekend and they're like nope you're not
headliners and we were like you know
setting up Monday Tuesday Wednesday a
bit drama and turning people away and
then we were like we just we just get a
weekend and they kept on saying no you
didn't really have credits back then
and all that stuff let's note shutting
out Monday or Tuesday windy so there's
my god so then we were like hard night I
called my this is when we decided to
take it upon ourselves at labels hat I
called Maas I said hey man you know this
is [ __ ] we should you know we should
take it to the next level and he said
great let's rent a theater so we rented
we went to the Lisner auditorium that's
what it was
Lisner auditorium it's set I believe
1,400 seats and we turned away 200
people and the improv managers came down
and they're like eh you could we should
have oh yeah we never went back we just
always did theaters at all really
because we knew we knew we had it all
you know an audience we were making like
we made $54,000 that night and one night
let you know we split it all but still
we are willing our money huh young
topics and that's that's that's tengo
hambre total retired after that no but
its entry I mean when our expenses were
limited shows we didn't do any radio we
didn't buy any ads it was all email
word-of-mouth
you know just we're out there just like
you know huh because we're out there
remember when we were touring Maz and I
had the system he would be up you know
like the matrix on his computer doing
his email blasts I'd show up in this ie
I'd show up in the city like a week
early and we'd budget you know hotel
room every night expenses and I'd go out
and do all the you know groundwork like
just although like passing out flyers
shaking hands kissing babies going into
local businesses you know getting the
community involved and going to the
people at the top of the pyramid really
like not to the scale of what Kevin Hart
did but you know he had that you know Jo
koy a lot of comics have that like go
out talk to the people in the community
they'll bring all the fans that's that's
kind of how you know how it worked and
then that ended you know taking off we
went to the Middle East we sold out
20,000 seats in one month in like five
countries and we did a whole tour there
and shot that so it was a cool time
capsule of my life you know to try to go
back and repeat that I don't know I know
you when you did Last Comic Standing Roy
Wood jr. said you guys had a blast on on
the bus you guys were going around
America on that bus yeah I want to hear
about that because I only heard his
stories all that it was awesome but I
was asking him like what was because if
you had one last
comics yeah I one last comment standing
and I was getting paid more than them
every night and going up last and he got
the best room on the bus right
no no room in the buzz where we got the
room first I was our but you know what
um we're on the tour arm
everything was tied you know except
there you know like the guy who who
feels that he lost the guy next to me
Tommy John again he kept going over like
he was due 2015 he would do 25 26 and
then keep going over that channel like
wait I'm like I'm either as a comic I'm
like I run while you're trying to go
over we're gonna win over the crowd
I read already one day let's go vote
like privilege I won the so much car I
am the people's champion and I just let
him you know I could talk to you know
say hey [ __ ]
stop going over your time but I read
that the money yeah IRA got the cash or
the squeeze you keep going over he was
late to the bus like 40 minutes late 35
minutes late I would like it is me yeah
you know we could leave without him
right you know but we waited you know
other stuff you know what's going on
going over you know and then like I was
mad I was high most of the time hahaha
everywhere I went
Flint Michigan somebody showed up gave
me a quarter hours a week and these are
rednecks bro who just showed up to see
me that's why they showed up these guys
brought that I normally bought us all on
TV I said I mean that mean these guys
could never be friends yeah well I have
a I have a job that I do a marijuana job
that I do and like probably 99.9% of the
time after the show somebody always
comes up to me and hands me a bag of
weed or a joint or something it's
actually really cool because you don't
need to find a drug deal in every street
after was before I brought I just wish
to joke to coke ha ha ha ha I'm so glad
that I wasn't out partying I met a man I
was not partying am i mad cuz man I
thought on that bus I put I wouldn't be
this big a [ __ ] suck just I'm pouring
over
[ __ ] my dealer their dog stuff like
that you know and I
I just do my thing man I got over that
we had 85 cities
I heard 85 City a guest tours and um I
was just happy to be it was my first
time actually on the tour was a bus it
was my first time like traveling every
night getting up and going somewhere I
left a lot of stuff man did you guys did
you guys have brakes
no no brakes you guys hit 85 cities
back-to-back which is a break for
Christmas a week off lifting that so
you're also doing a little bit of shows
in between your own children like it was
funny man like we were in we're in
Philadelphia we were at a place called
Allentown and um it was like it was all
white people right all white people and
I didn't die oh no you know I learned a
lot historian I learned like what chose
not to say what not to do and then I'm I
remember um he went the Tommy went over
at that shoulder like he went over I can
he will do 15 he did 27 and then when I
went up on stage and I look to the
audience all right oh I see why I don't
know why I said I see why why he went
over again you know cuz he was hurt man
because in the front row there was five
white old people and they had team
Felipa sure I mean five all white people
team Felipa people and this guy right
here beloved comedian from Bob and Tom
you know you were the Bob Tom favorite
I'm not a Bob time favorite he's the
he's the favorite a man you know I want
to let your wardrobe I swooped under
brawl from okay
and I came out of nowhere you did
actually no no no the comedy a new me
the comedy world new you yeah for
America the America didn't last Comic
Standing diva man I was that's what
that's a great I think if you can get on
a platform like that and really showcase
your talent and have experience and have
experience behind it not yeah come out
and think you're funny
because you're funny at the office or
whatever so there's always those guys
are funny in front of their friends
right you know I'm glad that they have
to be like a guy who won that comic
standing they'd have to prove myself to
everybody right walkers well he wasn't
funny but
people the Communists deliverance up on
the southwest America new Oh Felipe
worse yeah but after man man I felt like
I fall like we like when I will go to
Arizona like when I was with her the
best part of the tour man because we was
a different place in what they were
doing like that many Mexicans you know
anywhere but he finally hit places with
her Latinos when we hit Corpus Christi
Texas not over it was over brought those
guy had to pack up the virgin ah for
real Tommy John again had to close he
borrowed tape for somebody to close his
box so nobody buying CDs ro goes one
line and it was just for me like Roy
would look at Tommy's ah yeah man yeah
yeah you wanna I love Roy it was a line
around the block man man I don't know
Matt my mouth purple smiling broker I
just looked over again okay I guess i
wad huh I got the electoral vote I want
the electro ball roll let's do it I went
on tour with Roy Wood for a we did at
Sullivan & Son tour with Steve Byrne and
Owen Benjamin
so it's Owen tall white guy six foot
seven white guy Steve half-asian
half-white myself Arab Roy black we're
going no tour manager no nothing just
going in our car around America pulled
up in Houston this girl came up to me
after the show she's like how come you
guys don't have security at your manager
whatever you know you're in Houston
somebody who you know you'll get held up
here I was like nah we're good we got a
black guy with us you know what they got
Roy Wood jr. with us I think whenever
you have a black person with you people
are just a little bit hesitant to want
to approach you that often [ __ ] yeah
that cause you got an Arab and a black
guy then it's just like all right back
off double trouble so we linked the
weapon Roy was to handle his liquor by
the way he's a monster comedian a - man
that guy I'm telling you I watched a lot
of comedy and he is a craftsman the way
he does it you know and his his the
polarity and his voice and the octaves
and he's got this little bit of a knot
to relating to Bill Cosby but he's got
that voice sweet rhythm via Rivlin stuff
and yeah he's a monster dude he was he
spoke really highly of you
what you stand up there talk you know me
I gotta be I gotta be whimsical how to
make faces at you
cuz I put my iphone are you you got a
poker here with my eyes there'd be the
bug man will you when you started
stand-up were other crazy guys - they're
like Sam Kinison all together they're
all dead
nah thanks for I don't know why you put
me in that kind of my man I'm not that
bad that battle I've been about I
thought when I was this we was gone when
I got there okay chewy was there when I
got to the comedies well I will actually
I started doing it with you when I got
to the comedy store it was like Joe
Rogan Eddie Griffin
Charles Fleischer Charles flesh like
that and then it was like when they were
yeah all those sort of but then Rogen
he'd left for 15 years and came back and
then Eddie Griffin got kind of phased
out of there and then this new crew kind
of came in it was like me Bret Ernst
Sebastian Maniscalco Maz Jobrani Sam
Tripoli Mike Mike young Mike young Mike
Young like that you know the generation
and then we had loved and boom Shakalaka
boom Shakalaka ha ha ha the Comedy Store
that's an insane asylum that please
really man
I don't know there's no they don't
perform there I don't perform there
anymore I had you know I had a little
bit of a phasing out with what the
managers they were like God but you
manager the old ones the new ones when
we had a changing of the guards the
booking never liked an organ Tommy
no more times how it was cool with me
Tommy was great to me and funny like if
I talk bad about him but he was where he
was good no no shake his hand
hang on to it Philippe you want to go up
right now yeah yeah yeah I got I just
got tied to politics got weird like the
inmates started running the joint now
seriously I know I literally had the
manager of the Comedy Store say to me
you're not as relevant as you used to be
which was funny because I was in GQ
magazine and Playboy magazine right the
same week he was saying that [ __ ] it was
like go go to the newsstand pick up the
[ __ ] papers guy what do you what your
head at relativity relevant and his
anyway I was kind of man you know you
have to write a new special he was kind
of was like you're not my manager you
don't know what I'm doing in my career
and then he's
I've been instructed by comics to not
book you I said are you [ __ ] kidding
me he said nope I said who was it can't
tell you and I was like alright then it
just got dirty then I felt the dirt you
know at the place that's like I moved to
New York like last September and I've
been having a blast in New York because
none of that [ __ ] exists in New York if
you're funny you're funny and then you
go to another spot and you go to the
other spot people don't get caught up in
the comedy politics I think in New York
like they did here in LA don't you think
I don't know I don't know I think that a
lot of people hang out like vultures do
that's why it's like that you know well
there's there's only three clubs so
that's all you can do but in New York
you can go you know the Comedy Cellar
thinks the hottest club there to even
hang out in they have good food a nice
restaurant little bar area but there's
literally you know dozens and dozens of
clubs around New York City so you don't
have time to linger around one place all
night right well lingering early on
Santa Paula matters a lot of sad faces
in that world laugh a lot of communities
which should be somewhere doing a spot
wanna watch another creator perform and
then gave a dirty look when it gets off
yeah oh yeah [ __ ] that's a weird
little [ __ ] thank you I don't have to
start basis when I couldn't get bottom
feeders when I couldn't get spots I will
just go start a room yes I remember
Dublin's dub Liz she's next our dojo
room yeah yeah all right people think it
was dad's room because Jay was the
frontman of it but and I I was booked in
the room for the first two years and
then it started getting really creepy
comics for calling in the middle of the
night I'd have comics call me up and say
hey man I need to get laid tonight God
can I swear to god I need to get my
didn't go up on I do I need to get laid
like young I need to get laid can I go
up tonight and just do five minutes
olive even to a tight three because if
you went up at Dublin's and you killed
you got laid I'm hitting that line I did
a spot and I got a hug first I feel like
I went up like maybe three times and I
was the first time I went up and I was
just finished writing as Joe's life raft
at the mother joke and then we're around
Bret Ernst came up to me and you know
Sam Tripoli he was macking but you
better not leave oh you were like a rock
star up the room they stick around so I
waited bro
there's some drunk-ass she was outside
hey so whatever they brought taking the
kiss the hug was a goodbye kiss
[ __ ] against every comments you were
hot every comic that performed there and
killed got laid he was Jodie remember
Joe beer I'm getting a [ __ ] y'all
stairs let's go to her purse - Katrina
and I [ __ ] saw her as a sort of seal
off her [ __ ] purse and so far what's
this dossier ha ha ha that's a good
impression with your better one who a
bro you know I got nothing to say it's a
good impression Felipe Esparza I'm a
little tired today
but anyway I'm a little [ __ ] weasel
you know the kites and [ __ ] the little
daughter but we're gonna leave it like
that
but uh I was gonna answer in the college
I do the exciting one other than ask you
because you know when everybody does Joe
Diaz the pressure is usually too hyped
up long slow down a bit
yeah talk to me like a [ __ ] you know
I don't know but um you had a show
called rock comedy at the comic store
before that right no so what happened so
we did okay so we're like everybody's
showing up in the rocks of Dublin
Dublin's and the comedies are not
Dublin's or the Laugh Factory in the
comedy store weren't doing that well no
no yeah that's when I wish to mention
and then we started this room at
Dublin's and we did it for four years
straight sold out every Tuesday you know
hot chicks celebrities they could kind
of got things for days I was voted to
write Jane Cocco and Alonzo Bodden right
he Alonzo Bodden would close the show
every night you're like this jazz said
he'd sit down and just talk to the
audience like you know this old wise
black man people would just go nuts for
him but dangerous tool in a school think
like he was preaching like you know and
then and then yeah Mongo's at that show
bro and then and then Dane Cook came in
about two years in and he just blew the
hell up and that room he became like the
rock star quarterback and he was he'll
say to this day that room was the last
time comedy was innocent for me because
after that he did stadiums he like went
all over you know he became you know he
had a lot of family stuff happening
whatever and personal [ __ ] people in
holic but he said Dublin's man that was
the one comedy was innocent for me it
was the last time I remember comedy
being in its own I thought that was cool
because it did have an innocent
in a sense to itself because it was a
standalone room and then Pauly Shore
came in one night with like five like
really hot like you know dirty like
playmate we can bowling from him he goes
he was like hey buddy he's like this is
a great room when we kind of asked us
about it and we said you want to go up
on stage sure he went up on stage he
killed because everybody is obvi know
how Pauly Shore Dewees up and then he
came up to us after he's like hey you
guys want to bring this show over to my
mom's Club The Comedy Store so we
started doing Thursday's over there we
called it rock comedy and we had rock
and roll like DJ you know play rock and
roll music in between and we took the
best of the best from Dublin's and put
him up on that stage and I would just
throw myself up in the lineup and that's
what I got past at The Comedy Store
Mitzi shore saw me one night me Bret
Ernst and Sam Tripoli all got past the
same night cuz she was in the room
watching the show she came up to me
afterwards she said hang around funning
you're adorable - are you array big haha
I said I saw an Egyptian she goes oh
really you know we used to be your
slaves all hiragana shall it over let's
wash away she walked away and then they
called me the next day they're like she
likes you she passed you the good old
days that's funny man went numb you know
could access the comedy knows that those
fools Maz this guy I met I made and the
other dudes let his name oh the other
guy me too
yeah another guy bro it's like then you
guys were the first right so you get I
hear the first but so then you have like
newer Arabs coming in you know that it
turns into like Latino a lot of credit
our wheels in the company called a man I
do that'll turn it of Arab comedy now
where do you get that because we got
Latinos to money I don't do [ __ ] joke
bro [ __ ] beat her dog you and I are
gonna get poor over the same [ __ ] I'm
sorry we look alike like parle-g will
tell me well you know before like the
portal people get on my case those a
little I was throwing tortillas at the
time
who I was I don't know what 20 years
later when we stopped at Paul once you
stop going to tear you thing with dreams
of TV telethon he go to Tia and I hit
the camera member and what it all hit
hit the camera they were blocky but
being you just see the vomit chopping
you without doing a good old hockey I'm
like a SNL sketch but he invented in
there's another comet that was doing a
ball a dog that we're just going yo soy
tu atea that apology what's the laughs
thank you hey I was doing that shade 79
yeah damn what's uh whatever happened
with um I don't know if you guys like
are in touch with other friends but
Mencia he's around he's around yeah all
the clubs were you know Felipa does he's
always you know [ __ ] selling out two
weeks in a row and [ __ ] he's around he
did enjoy Diaz his podcast by the way
yeah he would probably like two months
ago I said where he's able to shoot
everybody yeah word that he was uh he
was thinking about going on the comedy
store and shooting everybody
okay I'm not with him anymore right if
that's it that's all I know the Hat gun
come out the little flag says Bay mmm
crazy he was all fresh ticket oppressed
within episode hi hello fresh a farm to
box company that sends you all the
French ingredients and the recipe you
need to create happy healthy satisfying
meals they currently offer a classic box
our veggie box and a family box you can
order three to five meals per week
designed for two to four people
well three go ahead and he's all happy
yeah right most recipes take just 30
minutes to prepare man cuz man you don't
want to wait an hour to eat or tortillas
Brandi wants way more than 30 minutes
people wanting it now most recipes do
take 30 minutes to prepare but Hollow
French is now offering light summer meal
that has jet introduced breakfast they
just introduced breakfast options really
get it get a breakfast to go the cost
breaks down to less than ten per meal
man that's cheap
so that's a $12 on breakfast sometime
box a meal
yeah the fresh ingredients measure to
the exact quantity needed so there's no
food
man because you know man we waste food
and hellofresh delivers to the food to
your doorstep in a recycle bowl
instantly bar for free we had this meals
servant for one week we chose the veggie
box and my favorite was the tex-mex
risotto so good and everything was on
our porridge waiting for us and we got
home I was surprised too that every
waiting for our poor juices tomatoes
Taylor you know because just food that
left behind all the ingredients for the
each meal in a separate little boxes so
easy so easy when you don't want to
think about too many for dinners you
don't have to go to a store for any
missing ingredients that always happens
to me I go home and I buy Syria to
forget to get milk our listeners because
you're a once-off food podcast listeners
we're gonna give you $30 off the first
week right of hellofresh by going to
hello friends calm and enter promo code
full 30 that hello friends come and use
promo code for 30 yeah man I don't know
what I'm the news are talking about a
thousand jobs are hired for retail we
chose dead people delivering food now
yeah well Amazon Amazon delivering food
Whole Foods was sold to Amazon yeah a
lot of stuff has changed I when you were
like when I'm when I made a message
stand up and when I started standing
with the Comedy Store I think the only
pillar that they were fooled with Pete
Dada yep right down the street and it
opened uh Domino's maybe I wasn't a fun
man like like like you like you said
before um before now you know before you
know where to go with me before you knew
what you were going before you knew
where to take your comedy or your or
your your [ __ ] comedy where is gonna
go the whole innocence of not knowing
where or it was gonna go it was so fun
huh yeah that was the best part of it it
wasn't it not knowing the journey and
then you arrived and you're like wow I
got here you know not that like that
like he doesn't happy we're happy yeah
but I didn't do anything spectacular but
I did some cool thing I you know it's
funny I actually wrote in my journal
things I wanted to accomplish as a
comedian and I think I did most of them
so it's interesting what you kind of put
out there and where you land sometimes
it's not you don't land where you think
you're going to land like I thought I
was going to be an American you know
like I am American but you know a lot of
people have classified like I'll do like
you probably get a lot of these Latin
shows or fest or whatever like I'm doing
this festival called the halal fest or
it's just like you know Muslim comedians
and it's nice to do that for the
community but I don't want to be locked
in as the Muslim comedian or pigeonhole
ya or the Arab comedian you know what I
mean like I like to what I'm trying to
do more and more is just outreach into
just cross-cultural you know communities
it's it's really it can get really
pigeonhole II you know I think that do
you we get like when they're looking for
um get the Middle East of comedian so
the matter Arab Persian whatever you
will feel like they got that
[ __ ]
like honestly going on there always go I
went through that too you know like they
got that [ __ ] ever do comedy 20
years right you know but then again stop
breaking it down well in graduate from
high school
I think we're from college and what we
really put to be speaking to these kids
right you know I always get hey we know
how much would it cost to bring you for
this gig and then I quote them okay
great we'll get back to you that sounds
great and then you know they'll blow me
back I'll see the put you know the post
on Facebook that he booked somebody else
yeah but we got marching I mean II know
I'm always curious like yeah you know
what the deal breaker is that they
always undercut my feet of course so
don't say oh we got him for this much
instead of that much Michael then you're
going to get that much comedy oh man I'd
say a story right now I tell you a story
about a guy who hired I'm another to me
I won't say the name cuz you know he
said this guy go they I want to hire for
example I want to hire a middle man you
know I got I'm twenty five thousand
dollars he he'll do it I'll let me ask
him I meant we got this gay for five
grand will fly you out to Hawaii Grouch
work with a hotel and if you want to be
like extra person go ahead
it's coming out of your five oh you say
yeah you say yeah I'll do it I love to
do it then the other guy cuts a ting
Dave 20 just because you got the phone
call right but you know that that's the
way it works
you kind of get upset you were happy
with a five grand right but I need to
know about the other no but it happened
a lot
have you ever fought night all the time
that's hard I guess no because it's um
just like oh I so [ __ ] relate to this
here happens all the time especially in
the Middle East you know I hate to say
it there's a couple legit promoters I
work out there with but a lot of them do
exactly that they go to the sponsor they
get a hundred thousand dollars from a
sponsor to give the artist ten or
whatever there's no no we have expenses
there's always expenses like hidden
expenses light to the microphone a
little microphone really that's all
we're not a bad little sound yeah
there's no logical you know flames and
[ __ ] like that and pyrotechnics
it's a mic and a stand and some light
and put some chairs up you know what is
a twenty grand to do that was the rest
so yeah but I've probably been you know
screwed over tens of thousands maybe a
hundred thousand dollars over the course
of my career
yeah and sometimes sometimes you know do
they agree to pay you a certain amount
and then you go do the gig you know they
give you a deposit they say as soon as
you're done with the set you get a check
or the wire for the balance and then
they always say we didn't saw enough
tickets or something has something
happened and then they don't pay you and
the great thing about the Middle East
not the great thing the screw up thing
is they always say you know well you
know my lawyer will be contacting you
[ __ ] you swimming today assuming in
Egypt you can assume in Saudi Arabia
you're going to sue me and he's go I
dare you to hire a lawyer to fly over
here to try and Sue me you're going to
spend more money than you're going to
make you know make back so you just kind
of wash your hands from it you know and
say well hopefully I don't do that next
time
damn that's that's tough to get all your
money upfront if you're going to leave
the country or you do a gig make sure
all the money is upfront you know or
make sure you have some sort of
especially when we do overseas gigs
that's the word should go overseas and
you don't get the money you're like Anna
I flew all the way across the world for
this [ __ ] didn't get deposit
got a couple of those I did before I was
at one last Carmen I did a show for some
guy he paid me well there the second
time I offered the positive right I
trusted actually barely come to the
money the first time I came in here
hahahaha we want to do a second show the
next year all right man you said me 500
dollars abroad and then when we do the
gig you just pay me the two it was 700
right so he didn't send the 500 right I
never I never got the 500 and then the
show gets moved up a week before the
show the show get moved they want me to
do you want me to do the next show that
following month and I told him nah man
you stole me $500 bro for the other get
you cancelled you never similar deposit
but you never did to show us all the
deal was I get the $500 it's up to you
to put up the show so if you don't pay
me $1,000 up front now I'm gonna do that
show so I basically told him no it's a
run sometimes you got to burn a bridge
so you know Angelo tsarouchas yes he
said he gave me the great greatest line
ever we were talking about burning
bridges in Hollywood in our business and
he said man you're gonna burn a bridge
make sure you walk across it first bro
I'm always like well I walked across
that [ __ ] a thousand times I
don't need to do it again come on bro
work with me dawg
as you know Suruga is a he's a comedian
from Toronto and that fool arm you know
some people read tarot cards some people
read pubs differ reads coffee ground oh
yeah that's why it feels great he's
Greek from Canada he grew up with
Russell Peters him in Russell nod yeah
I've been on I've been all over the
world with Angelo he did I've made a
documentary that not to shamelessly plug
it but I plug it bro get a documentary
called just like us it's on Netflix
right now and I took ten American comics
to Dubai Lebanon Egypt and Saudi so it
was like Whitney Cummings Sebastian
Maniscalco Maz Jobrani Tommy Davidson is
in it or me Jalili but Angelo was was in
it and we took him to Egypt and he was
fascinated by Egypt because he was like
I can't believe this bro there's the
pyramid over there there's like Pizza
Hut
I want to confine the pyramids but I
really want pizza and we put him on this
camel and you know he's like well over
400 pounds I think the big dude yeah we
put him on this camel bro and the camel
was like yeah I mean the camel barely
got up and we were all clapping we
thought the camel was gonna Nappanee
this is like an episode of Mythbusters
shall we live alone beat it tell ya the
straw didn't break the camel's back
we'll give him a little salute he's a
funny dude man he's a great comic to
tour with because he likes to a lot of
comedians like to sit in their hotel
rooms all day and battle depression and
watch watch no I've done it you're
watching like Dateline eating like like
bucks if you get it pissed off yeah
eating microwavable food from the lobby
and then I'm just Angelo's always like
come on let's go walk around he likes to
go walk around and see the city do [ __ ]
some comics don't don't like to do that
you like to do that I like to do [ __ ]
[ __ ] to do yeah that's true
like when I was in those Chattanooga
Tennessee I was it staying at the best
part of Chattanooga the the choo-choo
trains there was no nothing else to see
right Missy yeah when I was at go to the
movie we're in Chattanooga yeah or the
mall you know the others always said go
to go see a movie during the afternoon
just killed two three hours that way
especially if you're in the city I was
in Cincinnati you know Gary cannon no he
has a podcast with Steve Byrne right
yeah it's called gentlemen's mojo I
think whatever but uh we were in
Cincinnati man and he wanted to go to a
strip club so we went to the strip club
that was the size of this room damn at
pvap and this one there was one girl up
on the pole like a little bit away from
us and you know he's like políticas he
lived a dollar he's like hey can you
come over here so I can and she goes can
you throw it over here I have a bum knee
they're like you got a bum knee yeah i
disabled strippers in cincinnati down
she was on a pogo stick
that's that uh chipper on the crutch she
wanted that dollar 20 you come get it
the only dates coming up bro you wanna
plug yeah then I uh I'm going to Hawaii
on Roseanne Barr has this comedy summer
series I guess oh cool so it's in
Honolulu I'm doing the Blue Note in
Honolulu on July 19th and then go on
doing Mao Jay Davis has a room in Maui
now at the dirty monkey in Lahaina I'll
be there July 13th or 14th and then you
can go on my website I'm ed I'm ed calm
and all my dates are up there anybody
listening in China I'll be in China in
October yeah I know hey uh you know they
were comedy club lot of comedy club huh
yeah kung fu comedy I'm doing have
you've done that mentor give you done
that gig every time I tell someone other
like two books that you're here that
comment or say that who books that
should look at that email River Paul
yeah yeah I've never told me my first
time I'm doing claw Kuala Lumpur
Malaysia and Singapore so I'll be fine
and then we're doing a potential we're
planning access of evil reunion tour so
if you're listening in the Middle East
it will probably start in the Middle
East
get some Kuwaiti listeners Kuwait a
minute Kuwait's funny I come up with
mods to Kuwait rich the first time yeah
and then they they're just never money
oh yeah it was oil money but there's not
that much to do in Kuwait but they were
all it was also their first comedy show
so the promoter said okay guys this was
ten years ago
okay guys here's the deal you could not
talk about sex drugs religion or
politics good night good night so like
all right whatever Maz raises his hand
he's like ah I do a joke where I say
[ __ ] one time it's not okay the
promoters like my own you'll put them in
a bug place and I'm like I have like 46
locks just right now and he goes okay it
is a deal each of you couldn't have two
bucks we're like two like an we're
negotiating profanity religious a clean
comic day you could borrow two trucks
from and then we're driving to the show
and the guys phone rings ah no yes I'm
going to axis of evil coming the guys
without no other way to the show
I told
making up to what do you mean I just
wasn't gonna okay fine colors but guys
no [ __ ] so it's like I've never done
that before I've never been in a
situation sometimes you'll do like
certain gigs where the person says hey
there's children in the room or keep it
cleaning or whatever you know there's a
clean set but in the Middle East they're
just like it was just like I can't say
this can't say that you can I mean yeah
it's changed the first ten years ago I
got banned from Dubai for a year
damn we actually talked about it my
documentary but I did a joke not even a
joke it was an observation about a
nightclub and a mosque right across the
street from each other in Dubai so we
parked at this mosque and we walking
across the street to the nightclub so it
was like eight o'clock you hear the love
in here so I was like should we pray
should we dance you know and it ended up
on our axis of evil special on Comedy
Central than eventually on YouTube and
somebody like over there saw it and they
banned me for a year because I said I
was insulting Islam and Shan tricked
over there on your black black people
problems bro I'm black
technically North African that's crazy
huh you can't eat bugs
well women feel once I don't know no in
an Audi and Saudi was like that some of
the shows the other daily joke I did
they have the only seven star hotel in
the whole wide world and Dubai it's
shaped as a sailboat
it's like architectural phenomenon and I
was like how did it get seven stars and
I said Amir you know said you know I
give it something started this my hotel
I'll give it 11 if I want you know so it
would got a laugh but it was more like
not making fun of him as more like this
guy is that powerful he can do that and
then boom they throw the hammer down on
me you can be insulting our leader and
they just a leader of our city and I
loved you by you know but it can have a
little bit of hypocrisy going on
that sounds were you know there's a lot
of Western stuff happen in there you
know sort of in-your-face prostitution
and there's a tit nightclub scene no
fees the you know part I think part of
the economy in some way you know
businessmen coming in from all over the
world is the biggest business but then
you know if you get caught with like a
little bag of coke it's 15 years in
prison not that I would do that or bring
it a little bit might be the best coke
you've ever had I don't think you'll
ever go the drive relationship Jose I
could do yeah so make him up huh you
will bring wife to your house and she
will not worth five cows you saying I
see that worth five cows well they have
a muslim david joke passages i swear god
is it like that
it's called muslim single i think a
muslim singles and i'm what you don't
have to die low you can have that bro
[ __ ] hilarious it's all yours
it's a funny app because it's cool cuz
all the people in the community get to
interact but i'm lies you don't even
know what any of the women look like you
know it's like hi I'm Nadia I like long
walks with a falafel in the occasional
hot tea they're like hey Nadia you have
beautiful eyes you show me the rest your
face sure no problem
Wow full front when I know honey wait it
was hard me I like to date take long
wash behind my man I like to drive just
kidding
I kill my ovaries remember that that's
crazy when they did it they were about
to allow women to drive another radio
system somebody passed or turn or
alternate on fake news order and said
that it might hurt your ovaries evil
woman's right right they'll say anything
to keep putting food and when I said I
mean it the others comedian of others
the comedian um
this Arab comedian he wrote a song that
went viral because he's Muslim
and he took the song from mom don't
worry that Bob Marley song be happy neat
no ah no woman knocked no quiet but he
took a road I remember when you used to
sit in the backseat of my car
no woman no drag no woman no drives and
I'll play on it yeah funny man the
Middle East man he never done the Middle
East ever imagine you guys get the
Midwest bad enough not there is of
course over him you guys would uh you
guys would killed and understand it I
like you do agree we should we should
bring you over there they're trying to
talk to you I told you this tour manager
was trying to get a hold you to do
Southeast Asia in the Middle East by
Grande you keep 20 what you did the
covers without borders right with
Russell I did yeah Russell hosted that
it was funny cuz you know Scott Montoya
battery so Scott used to manage me and
then when we stopped working to take it
80 percent hey I love Scott Scott just
you know he was working over at this
place called the collective I think and
and he you know he's a great producer I
think managing talent was not probably
something he enjoyed doing and also
under the circumstances he had it what
I'm being really PC right now but anyway
but uh he came back and was producing
all these showtime specials comments
without borders and stuff and I was - a
fish 'l yeah I remember he run the same
thing and I was touring with Russell
Peters in Australia I didn't know the
Russell was back then and Scott called
me up he's managing at the time and he
said do you think Russell would host he
said well we're trying to get one more
Valderrama I think it was the guy the
guy from seventies show yeah that is
name Wilmer Wilmer and he said you know
he doesn't want to do some weird
political thing that happened do you
know anybody that might want to do it
like a celebrity like he was trying to
lean toward Vince at he wanted me to a
dance I said I know for sure Vince
wouldn't do this I said what about
Russell Peters I'm standing right next
to him in a Sydney Airport and he's like
oh yeah I didn't think about that
I just leaned over and I said would you
be interested in doing that and he said
you know sure it did he had a producer
fee or whatever EP and then Clayton his
brother did the deal but that's how that
happened I just I didn't take I didn't
get my percentage gotta get my 20 grand
said the kite
but yeah Russell's fun to work with man
Russell took me to Australia and sold
out thousand bro he sold 30,000 tickets
and he wasn't he was just climbing back
then and we and this is an author's in
five cities we did Perth Adelaide Sydney
Melbourne and Brisbane and you know
we're we're calling him Elvis parsley ah
that guy man he's just like he was
getting popped left and right Asian
Indians all over him and I was just like
who is this guy I never met him and he
asked me to go on tour with him I never
even met him he said I saw your axis of
evil thing and I'm going on tour and
looking for a cool comic to bring with
me and I was like I said why me
he said I heard you like went in I said
yeah I think so
he said so why I was back to another
night with him bro yeah yeah yeah he
basically was like you know I need a
good wingman just stay out of my way
kind of thing hell yeah and I did I was
you know he treated us nicely you know
ray shake his body his bodyguards and we
went all over man Russell does it in
style bro you know Elliot everything's
first class always picking up me buying
people expensive watches and SH I had
one you gotta watch yeah I know what I
gotta watch I got the tag on a tag watch
would you get a two how he's spending
like five six seven grand on his watches
you know like it just don't getting them
away by candy but when you're making 21
million dollars a year get it I guess
you could do that spitting out those
bench I had to tag my sponsor
tag my sponsor you know go to watch
because I follow this page I met I met
where this I like when you say my name
of all times most people don't do that
there was just say I'm ed I manage like
a first name I'm in event it was like
this page I follow right cuz oh you know
me you know you like you statement my
hotel room fighting depression
everybody lies tomorrow they want to go
too hot so you know just went through
Instagram following pages and
to getting stuff and I hit up on a page
called tag the sponsor because I had to
follow these chicks right it says these
hot models and they go to and I'll keep
it up because they like going to the
same places to buy the last women like
to go home
her best places to be or New York Miami
Dubai and I wasn't [ __ ] the
attraction to the Dubai [ __ ] right then
then I thought hashtagging and I said
that what to tell your sponsor then it
has to be this guy pretending to be like
this rich Arab guy right and he was
taunting these girls or what do you do
you'll hear a hella a loja macbeth humus
back no that was right I did not know
what that was I thought they are they
stuffing hummus in her ass but I didn't
know that but now brother's jumping me
shits on these chicks right because
these chicks like I did one model she's
hot she puts a photo with her and
getting off a plane in Dubai getting up
in a plane in Dubai first class in Dubai
shopping in Dubai and I'm thinking [ __ ]
[ __ ] does not sell enough of these
shitty drinks that she promotes to go to
Dubai two times a year there's so many
women in Dubai that are taken care of
right and they have sweet-ass villas on
the palm islands they get mad money boys
yeah they get all the perks they need
and they don't have any sort of
emotional connection with the guy who's
fun to no party he's maybe somewhere
happy honey probably there was a lot of
other than a few people you know some of
these guys have and I know I know guys
in the Middle East who roll you know
they got like you know six seven women
always just entourage you know playboy
yeah I asked to look up the king of
Saudi Arabia but this guy is so rich
that he has his family is rich but he's
like here he built a prison just to lock
up family members who are [ __ ] up ha
ha ha ha ha you know family members I
haven't paid his [ __ ] taxi he'll lock
you up in that nice prison brought to
your [ __ ] you get your tie get a pet
tiger bro I ever did not have done that
gig in Seychelles
it's a Seychelles is this little tiny
island off the coast of West West Africa
and I went with Adam hunter one time
it's a
Island of Africa very small right now
we'll take it for ya
oh that place is like a [ __ ] paradise
so the guy there's a guy a prince who
who built a resort right next to the
Four Seasons right and it's like his own
little like built-in paradise and he
flies in escorts like 50 of them like a
couple times a month or whatever and
like five or six gay guys and you and
you get in flying to Seychelles you go
through Dubai you're flying to say shows
get picked up and check in on the hotel
to give you a temporary phone and like a
pager of the Booker and he says hey
we're going to call you at 6 o'clock or
whatever be ready a golf cart is going
to come pick you up we're going to take
you to the gig you're going to do the
gig you can't talk to the audience you
can't meet the audience afterward don't
look at the prints in the eyes all this
crazy [ __ ] and then you got to leave you
can't interact with an audience so we
get there and like you know the room was
probably like like a big living room
like a little jazz room and there's
always like hot women in there and a
couple like really like flamboyant gay
men and then there's prints in the very
back you could just see a silhouette of
him smoking this hookah pipe with a
couple women lingering around him
drinking me a bottle service I don't
know what it was and you do the set and
then Adam hunter Judas said he likes
dirty comedy an option a set we got
escorted out of there and I thought man
this guy and then they threw a big-ass
party I don't know what happens behind
those doors
but somebody Adam said wow I disguise
like you know they you know Prince in
Saudi or whatever and you know why would
he you know put a resort in this little
tiny island in Seychelles and I said
because God doesn't know where
Seychelles is I touch it no it's like
they just use its eyes wide shut bro oh
man and then it was a trip beautiful
island you know not fun if you're by
yourself it's good 50 hot women in the
room next door
why would she you got a Charlie Murphy
what what do you do is perform for
prints no legs woman they were to if
they go on a Big Island right with um
what's-his-name with James then really
James he talked about he talked about
Annabelle show Rick James told all the
horrors there if you want to stay here
don't [ __ ] Charlie Murphy
anybody [ __ ] Charlie Murphy a fire
all these chicks you like nope I want my
10 grand no they do that is what I like
how beautiful is it like the ocean home
in Seychelles yeah it's it's right there
almost with people right now dude it's
actually it's super beautiful it's kind
of a Caribbean you know style looking
island like white sand beaches I mean
it's it's gorgeous
there's nothing to do there like Adam
hunt you know Adam hunter we went and
found this bar like 10 miles away and
you know hanging out always like sort of
Caribbean locals but uh it's beautiful
all you know a lot of the beaches and
Middle East's are beautiful you know
it's Africa what South Africa [ __ ]
we're not taking a bit South Africa's
dope man you guys ever been there to see
pictures Cape Town South Africa all the
women look like Halle Berry
Dutch Dutch came in and rape and pillage
everybody [ __ ] Dutch making the world
pretty ha ha ha ha here's a cookie oh
you feel regular Dutch guy ugly
[ __ ] bro yeah well that is what
the mix who spit it out to backward
chakra but he bangs a white woman not
Ali barrier Bruno Mars I was Miss with
help she made that [ __ ] exotic yeah
when are you torn again oh my so I
started on and on September 30 I have a
HBO special
obviously my wife Lisa and I we produced
a congratulations we sold it to them and
gonna release it and would you shoot
that at the family improv are nice
that's a nice figure that's hot too
isn't it now I put a lot of comics a lot
of comics a haunted when they Bob that's
clear the air well the left I'm a man
talking about a lot every time every
time I showcase for anything it always
feel like a bomb so I don't feel like I
feel you on that Tonight Show set I know
whenever somebody says you know do this
and keep it in a box like what I wanted
to do is grab the microphone tell the
audience to shut the [ __ ] up and go into
my [ __ ] but you know Bob Reed was very
very adamant about you know just go up
make sure you say this do it this way
don't go out of the boundaries and all
along and I was so nervous back then
I ended up after I bomb do you know what
I went up to him in the hallway and I go
and I bond and Ross mark Ross Ross mark
yeah ratha mark he goes he goes no you
didn't and Bob goes yeah he did hahaha I
know who Bobby's gay yes you did you
know Bobby yeah so he go you kept his
shoe told you that so all the sparkle
even Sparkle sort of sort of I was cool
though he's very nice so he uh I said
hey I got love at the Comedy Store
do you want to follow me up to the
Comedy Store and I'll just pop I can pop
in and just do a set there and I'll just
do it over again he looked at mark Ross
when he was like yeah sure so they
followed me up to the Comedy Store they
parked in a lot they walked in the o.r
Tommy said you know I told him hey dude
I just bombed at The Improv over in
front of the Improv The Tonight Show
Booker's can I just go up and do type
five minutes of showings I guess so I
went up and I had to get set and that's
what kind of got me on the show
because you can't do comedy in front of
people I don't want to listen to it you
know and then have it tonight show
Booker's go you suck you know it was a
horrible feeling of my career that you'd
save them I got here there was a big as
a great save you got a show kids well
gee go for The Tonight Show but I like
that's a followed by Holtzman bro being
late so nice that we have a note 12:40
p.m. at the left I love how it's really
done
we're so booked upcoming shows July 13
through 15 or B incorporates Christi
Texas mesquite Street Comedy Club July
22 2013 Florida at the top of improv
July 27 to 29 Des Moines Iowa funny both
West August total is six that's right
they'll be live what you go Torres at
night and we'll find somebody else also
in August Brea improv Milwaukee check
out all the data Philippe the Worldcom
also man we moved right and we have a
lot of junk I met I met whatever we did
I have a [ __ ] yard sale so inviting
everybody from the podcast to buy our
[ __ ] when you ready move we must Granada
Hills oh nice once you're walking with
the gods stay over all this it's over
bro we want me to tell about we got we
had all the xxx sizes available it was a
fat boy you're
sell take everybody who showed up shout
out to Alex de large for bringing us
Jamba Juice in the morning also take you
to Victor from Eagle Rock who showed up
a brought us coffee in the day thanks
bro
Sandra kilos who brought vegan donuts
with Johnny rocky and Martin Rizzo
thanks to Martine emini for helping us
back our stuff are the leftovers check
him out a DC good man also a shout-out
to our listener Jose Rodriguez from
local 270 I didn't know that yes
yeah Messi you guys dumb you guys with
that before the axles are evil you guys
really open the doors for a lot of young
comics to actually like who are Middle
Eastern to actually wake up and realize
that hey man I could do comedy too cuz a
lot of people are territorial to you
guys like max Amini he's doing his thing
you know and I'm the other guy with a
long hair my homie I me okay I'm here
King yeah those guys are let you know
you probably have a very strong family
man like I will see you sister at our
mirror a mirror and on Ibiza yeah it's
awesome she loves you dude
your family with your dad's real cool
yep big family four sisters one brother
and I've been hard cuz you have a very
strong family maybe you'd be a comedian
what the [ __ ] I'm a damn it now cuz I
was I was like the least funny as to my
family and I and I did okay you know so
I always told my sisters you guys should
go into comedy and they were just like
hell it's just as loud and funny just
like my sister they're just they're just
out you know they're like I call them
the Egyptian Kardashians they're like
beautiful - you know like man they're
always trying to hit on them and stuff
but they're just like you know they're
like strong women and then yeah you know
all these middle-eastern comics I
started sort of orbiting around the axis
of evil it's nice to see actually that
there's a comedy community with that
voice you know the problem is is people
start stepping on each other's material
often so you try to really write
specific know the really used a
Pakistani I say Afghani right no dude
that's my joke dude
I when I was bad too bro but now but but
like very you are like the Richard Pryor
of that scene for them bro you were
performing yeah first I thought it
always would be first no matter what
like I always give props to pause Regas
to move first lady but you will it would
like the man who land on the moon a lot
of people thank you that by the way
because a lot of people I don't care
about credit and who did what first but
a lot of some of the comics I don't
really talk to anymore that I started
out with or that we're in the scene
coming up who want to claim that that
ticket I'm just like go ahead you know
everybody knows it was me
so I got the electoral vote yeah it was
usual do the rooms dog the People's
Champ no people's champion real acting
yeah I actually died I just did the
short film
speaking of dividing a laugh when I say
this I did this short movie that got
selected in the Dubai Film Festival this
year it's called the scapegoat and I
played as novelist who can sit full
drama suspense kind of thing completely
different from doing stand-up and I just
wanted to sink my teeth into something
as an actor therapeutically because I
was battling depression just like the
hotel room in the hotel room and therapy
can do it and you know work it out
talking to God Oprah Jesus whoever it is
sometimes that stuff just doesn't work
sounds like I need to sink my teeth into
something I started auditing acting
classes in New York City and that wasn't
when really jamming and then the script
came along a little 20 minutes short
film called the scapegoat this guy's a
novelist who has a week to finish a
novel because he just got a best-selling
one that's you know got almost acclaim
and he got to back up a secondary chance
to do another the book and he can't
write he doesn't know what to do so
because all the voices in his head are
controlling him so he invites all the
voices in his head over for dinner he
cooked some fish and and I play all the
voices so I play it was like four little
movies in one where you see me literally
like acting against myself which was
hilarious because all the body doubles
or the guys were saying my lines next to
me they would just mute the line and
thunder I say no damn it you need to
have you know explode oh god okay sorry
you're not it yeah but it was a fun
experience so yeah that's the last thing
I did before that at Sullivan so it's
been years since I've been on you know
done any acting but this movie was great
and it got selected in the Dubai Film
Festival so it's nice to have a little
project I get to go to Dubai again see
some friends go walk the red carpet do
that whole their film festivals out of
control but I spend like a hundred
million dollars and iron film festivals
it's crazy not not [ __ ] over there yeah
goodbye yeah man yeah we gotta get you
guys to the Middle East you gotta bro
seriously stand-up comedy is breaking
out now in Mexico but they're like it's
so new that they're stealing the jokes
from the Latino comedian and translate
them in standard ya know in certain a
manic it's like a hacking it's okay in
Mexico freaking right
so no border is [ __ ] yeah do you run
cuz I know that what's the name Park him
or her the gun Picabo Lana the comedian
Paul Kane was the name Paul he's very
very on straight comedian Ozzie not Paul
camp our double lion or the Chinese
comedian but Diane huh Paul Ogata Paul
Ogata he told me that Chinese kameena do
that I mean the the Asian comedian stuff
and making it Chinese you know it's an
Arab in Saudi Arabia um I think there
was a lot of that going on I don't know
if there was actually hacking jokes but
there was a lot of stuff that has
already said and then they do in Arabic
and it just sounds funny because they
relate to it yeah yeah you know the
stand-up comedy in Saudi Arabia by the
way is huge
again another subject matter my
documentary we talked about that but
it's like really growing over there it's
crazy
they have like millions and millions of
YouTube followers and mercedes-benz is
their sponsor and they get paid like
these guys are just starting out they're
getting paid like two three grand five
grand a show just starting out we're
making twenty five bucks a Gotham I know
when we first started on Montebello and
it was here well you can't
I always tell these Middle Eastern
comics to when you come to America it's
a different jam and like you may be
ready to put you know pull out your
shovel
start digging because you're going to be
in the trenches for a long time you're
not going to get paid two three grand
right out of the gate hell no ain't no
prints here please you ain't no prints
here plug your nose
yeah what I'll be is July 17th through
the 24th I'll be at the V theater with
Edward San Juan over there at Planet
Hollywood and also Wednesday nights in
Romano the Romano's
a Riverside man that I grew up yeah
where's that downtown said it called any
prominent I went in there oh really I
got a win tonight rude is it the
upstairs
yeah the contrary holiday dude I live in
LA I grew up there but yeah cuz I wanted
to tell you because I went a few a long
time ago but this dude named CL I just
didn't want to creep you on the show go
through with the book yeah I talked to
my buddy man he does Skanda he's an
actor he's the one that told me about
that little after-school special movie
with Vince Vaughn they get all cult or
is it what everyone's that everyone's in
I'll definitely come check that out
sounds fun yeah and who do you take on
the road with you orgy go all the time
yeah I want to come like open for you
guys hell yeah I'll host I'll just do it
just just to have fun I would just be
fine be a fun little group right it will
be three Brown guys thank you
three brown guys we're not sure what the
third guys from Riverside don't expose
them we're so full we got I met I met
again man this has been so much fun
coming on this park you know so funny is
I don't do I want to be like the podcast
snob yeah there's too many out there and
everyone is then I get a lot and like in
in LA in LA LA in New York you know
people just coming up with a little mini
podcast like let's do it in my car let's
do it like [ __ ] oh no no I'm gonna
literally their fridge stolen I did it I
did it I got I get up I get a comments
podcast in his car we're sitting in the
front of the cars and comes out II need
you want to seed and we just put a lot
of comics we'll say hey man and it's I'm
flattered you know and then it's like
I'm getting you know Klos isn't asked me
to come on the ratio show the comics are
always doing each other's podcast and
it's flattering because people go you'll
want to hear your story and we have
history whatever but a lot of the
podcasts they just don't find
interesting I don't listen to but when
you when we were talking on Twitter and
you said not even have your cell number
you said hey man come to my podcast why
the way I thought oh man that's going to
be [ __ ] fun
and because we have history and I'm just
really happy to see where you have taken
your career from the gotham days man
until now it's a feels exciting to be a
part of it so you're you ask me I was
like yeah am i go do this podcast hell
yeah bro I met I met a mulatto Lita I
always see the devil you see that so
that's Jeff there's a room in um in
Whittier sticks ha oh that's what oh you
mean uh
cute cute the Pelham yeah yeah I like
that rule bro that was a great you know
comedy and then you go it's a little
dark place and then outside you have
this like no there's no billiard hall
with like you know beer flowing and
people playing pool music cute girls I
was a fun room man hey honestly though
before you go back down well you had
that room you liked a lot of the people
used to do well but Luke Tori's to kill
they're hard bro yeah yeah you I used to
cool Roy huh I used to be cool with Luke
and he pulled a fast one on me one day
Oh guitar he used to destroy in this
room and we were actually really cool
I'm not throwing him under the bus I'll
say it to his face I said it before but
he he we just kind of stayed in touch I
didn't see him for many years and then I
was dating this girl who owned a
restaurant in Orange County that you
know she wanted you comedy in and I was
like sure let's do it you know and then
and then Luke started performing there
and then he like kind of took over the
room without me knowing kind of the old
know for sure else about this subpoena
movie and I called him on it and he
basically told me to [ __ ] off and I was
like and I was like I was just like hey
dude you know I'm a really nice giving
guy and you know you want to burn a
bridge with it great but just don't ever
ever ever ask me for anything because he
showed me his colors I was like you're
not even when we're done we're not even
good anymore I just thought it was
disheartening because you can trust a
lot of combat art industry so dirty and
backstabby and
worse than the music industry I think
you know and we're all individual
players so everybody's not it's not a
team effort unless more person
personalized it is and it's okay and
then you know they I think it's good to
bring people on board if you have that
type of confidence and creativity and
material and if you could afford to do
that you know a lot of comics are so
eager to get their own thing and then
you know the slightest thing you'll just
want to cut you out and I thought a lot
of people just throw [ __ ] daggers at
me left and rondelle and [ __ ] comedy
house of cards
ha ha ha ha I seen the British versions
even better all bad you and the British
show this office is amazing our neighbor
the shameless a British one no one happy
that's a bit better than American one
huh yeah because they're shameless over
there its chamber for the guests a with
[ __ ] sons girlfriend bro it is not so
full podcast this week we have our meta
man follow him hell yeah
and bring back the axles of evil to axis
of evil comedy tour at on that comedy if
you want to follow me on Instagram and
Twitter was so fool wasn't who check him
out next time he shows up at the will
burn in Boston
you kill it up there huh what